the African rainforest is filled with
all kinds of odd and fascinating
creatures this long tongue belongs to an
okapi who uses it to grab food the five
foot tall okapi feeds on leaves it
breaks down the tree limbs so that the
limbs won't grow up and out of its reach
scientists didn't even know about the
okapi until the 20th century
what is it its legs have markings
somewhat like a zebra which give it
cover in the jungle but its face is much
more like its relative the giraffe its
neck may not be nearly as long but like
the giraffe it spreads its legs to take
a drink unlike the giraffe the okapi is
extremely rare be glad you caught a
glimpse of this one